[Música]
desde la antigua Grecia hasta el siglo
XX Aristóteles Sigmund Freud y muchos
otros estudiosos buscaban lo mismo
testículos de
anguila la anguila europea o anguila
anguila podía encontrarse en los ríos de
Europa pero nadie la había visto
aparearse y pese numerosas disecciones
nadie pudo encontrar huevos de anguila o
identificar sus órganos
reproductivos sin información los
naturalistas propusieron varias
teorías Aristóteles propuso que emergían
espontáneamente del lodo plinio El viejo
argumentó que se frotaban contra las
rocas y los residuos resultantes
cobraban
vida otros decían que nacían en los
techos surgían de las branquias de otros
peces o incluso que surgían de los
escarabajos pero la verdadera historia
de su reproducción es aún más
complicada y para resolver este misterio
los estudiosos tendrían que reformularse
siglos de
investigaciones actualmente sabemos que
su ciclo de vida consta de cinco
etapas larvas leptocaulis
[Música]
angulon anguilas
amarillas y anguilas plateadas dadas las
grandes diferencias físicas entre estas
fases no sería extraño pensar que son
animales diferentes de hecho eso es lo
que los naturalistas europeos
pensaban Los investigadores sabían de
las
leptocaulis pero no pensaron que se
relacionaban con los angulon y las
anguilas amarillas que vivían a cientos
de kilómetros además las anguilas no
desarrollan órganos reproductivos hasta
más adelante y el tiempo que pasan en
los ríos de Europa Lo pasan como
angulon Entonces cuándo se reproducen Y
dónde lo hacen la vida de la anguila
europea empieza en las aguas Salinas del
triángulo de las bermudas en el pico de
la temporada anual de ciclones miles de
larvas de salen del mar de los
Argos de ahí siguen trayectorias de
migración a Norte a América y Europa
continentes que estaban más cerca Cuando
las anguilas establecieron estas rutas
hace 40 millones de
años en los siguientes 300 días las
larvas siguen las corrientes oceánicas
por 6500 km hasta la costa de Europa lo
que crea una de las migraciones marinas
más
largas
al llegar habrán crecido aproximadamente
45 mm y se habrán transformado en
angulas semitransparentes y no solo
cambia su apariencia si la mayoría de
los peces marinos entraran a las aguas
salobres de la costa sus células se
llenarían de agua dulce y
explotaran pero Cuando las anguilas
llegan a la costa sus riñones cambian
para retener más sal y mantener la
salinidad de su sangre un sinfín de
estos nuevos peces migra a arroyos y
ríos
[Música]
apilánez
en esta etapa crecen hasta medir unos 80
cm y por fin desarrollan órganos
sexuales pero la última fase de su vida
y el secreto de su reproducción sigue
siendo un
misterio en
1896 los investigadores identificaron a
las
[Música]
leptocarpha tiene que hacer un estudio
exhaustivo del océano para encontrar
larvas de no más de 30 MM y es aquí
donde entra Johannes schmith Durante los
siguientes 18 años este oceanógrafo
danés rastreó las costas de cuatro
continentes y encontró
[Música]
leptocaulis su migración los científicos
aún no las han visto aparearse en la
naturaleza ni han encontrado sus huevos
las principales teorías sugieren que se
reproducen en un torbellino de
fertilización externa donde los espermas
fertilizan huevos
flotantes pero las fuertes corrientes y
las algas del mar de los sargazos han
hecho que esta teoría sea difícil de
confirmar los investigadores ni siquiera
saben dónde Buscar ya que no han podido
rastrear una anguila durante el regreso
de su migración hasta enfrentar estos
desafíos el Antiguo misterio de estas
anguilas se nos escapará de las
[Música]
manos el océano está lleno de criaturas
curiosas y depredadores feroces con este
video conozca las increíbles
adaptaciones que hacen que el atún rojo
sea uno de los depredadores más
dominantes del océano o Explore las
capacidades de alto vuelo de los
calamares con este video